i volunteer as tribute the hunger games
was never afraid to push the limits when
it came to young adult adaptations
as the movies went on the plots got dark
but what if we told you the hunger games
franchise was supposed to be even more
twisted than what we saw on screen
today we're uncovering why the
filmmakers decided to leave out the
parts of the storyline that are so dark
you won't even believe
actually happened in the books
you want me to sing
with a song like the hanging tree and a
movie concept that focuses on the
destruction of kids
it's hard to imagine that the hunger
games films could have had a final
result even more
morbid than what we got but for book
readers that darkness
was a reality the missing movie scenes
start right from the first few chapters
of the novel
remember that avox that works as a
servant for katniss in the capital after
her first reaping
that wasn't the first time katniss was
meant to have seen her in the first
novel while katniss and gail are on one
of their usual hunting trips they
witnessed this girl being picked up by a
capital hovercraft while the boy she was
with was pierced through the chest
take off live in the woods that's what
we do anyway they'd catch us
maybe not of course it's no surprise to
us how dark the capital can be but this
scene at the beginning of the series
would have
definitely set the tone right away it
also showed katniss and
us that there truly was no way to escape
your district or the capital
in a later book there was also a scene
where katniss meets two people
bonnie and twill attempting to escape
district 8 after their families were
taken in an uprising
they're in search of district 13 but
when katniss arrives in mockingjay she
never sees them
which tells us that they most likely met
their demise
did these have a huge impact on the
storyline not really
however it would have shown us how
powerful president snow was before we
even got to know him
and the dark themes continued throughout
all three books while the movies either
altered the concept or cut them out
completely
even if i don't make it
during katniss and peta's cuddly cave
scene peta was meant to come
extremely close to passing away like so
close that katniss tricked pita with a
special broth dosed with sleep serum so
she could fight at the cornucopia for
medicine
and their rendezvous in the arena was
supposed to result in peeta losing his
leg when they got
back to the capital the movie opted to
make the cave scene more romantic than
gruesome
and we're definitely not complaining
team everlark
but on the other hand it would have
given a more in-depth look into how much
the hunger games affects even the
tributes that survive
so what happens when we get back
i don't know speaking of the tributes in
the books they weren't even safe after
being eliminated
remember how peta and katniss become the
winners they fight off the final tribute
cato
while the capital sends mutations into
the arena
this might be a little disturbing so
brace yourselves those mutations were
actually genetically modified to have
the same hair
and eyes as the fallen tributes yep
there was a mutation that
looked just like rue we all knew the
capital was twisted we just didn't know
to what level
suzanne collins actually wrote them to
be and it wasn't just the capital that
was a whole lot more intense
district 13 actually had some protocol
of their own that got pretty dark
remember nightlock the poisonous berry
that katniss threatened snow with in the
arena
well district 13 turned the berry into a
pill that their soldiers carried with
them in case they were compromised
we're not so sure why they left this out
but kept katniss's line to finic
nightlock in the film
[Applause]
this little tidbit doesn't seem like
much but when you really think about it
proves how hardcore district 13 is
and how chaotic it would have been if
the capital got any information on
district 13 and their whereabouts
district 13 was more important to these
soldiers than their own lives
we all fled on our own for this
left out scenes weren't the only things
the filmmakers decided to crop out of
the story
right there were plenty of characters
and characters backstories cut that
would have really brought the films to a
whole other level of darkness
hey mitch everyone's favorite mentor
congratulations
we love the movie haymitch but we can't
help but wish they introduced his grim
backstory instead of just
rushing over it he was of course a
tribute in the 50th hunger games
well let's just say his time in the
arena was comparable to how bad
katnisses was
embrace the probability of your imminent
death
he teamed up with the other district 12
tribute my silly donner
and then held her as she passed from
mutated birds sent from the capital
we never really got an answer on whether
or not there may have been something
deeper than friendship between haymitch
and may silly
but there is no denying he definitely
cared deeply for her
not only would his dark past have helped
us understand hey mitch and
his addiction problems but me silly was
actually katniss's mom's bff and the
original owner of the mockingjay pin
talk about full circle ready to work
good now moving on to some minor but
still very important
character stories we have the rest of
katniss and peeta's prep team
katniss was close with more of her
beauty squad than just
cinna you realize that your actions
reflect badly on all of us
and the same goes for peta but we never
really get to see those relationships
develop on screen
which might have saved us a lot of
heartache because as you've probably
guessed the story didn't end well for a
lot of them
while katniss's team flavius venia and
octavia managed to escape
peta's team was sentenced to their
demise on live television after the
tributes held hands
before the quarter quell these
characters would have made this scene of
the tribute's unity even more meaningful
and shown how much of a true rebellion
against snow and the capital it actually
was
this is the revolution and you're the
mockingjay
so now that we've gone over how much
darkness was cut out of the films we
can't help but wonder
why it's been mentioned before that
scenes dealing with any foreshadowing
were sometimes cut so it's not to spoil
anything for the audience
however the only scenes we can think of
that might have been a spoiler is
katniss meeting bonnie and twill and
hearing about district 13.
13 13 yes
there of course is the obvious reason of
time constraints tick tock
tick tock the average movie is max two
hours and if they'd included every
single book scene we'd probably be
sitting in the theater for a good four
hours
but that doesn't answer the question as
to why the majority of the scenes they
decided to cut were a bit
darker than those that kept in however
we've been inkling that keeping the
audience rating in check
might have been a big factor in cutting
out these darker scenes no matter how
dark and twisted the concept of hunger
games is at the end of the day
it's still a young adult series that
means the filmmakers had to be extra
careful to make sure their rating never
surpassed pg-13 for all four movies
if it didn't the movies would have been
made for an audience that probably
didn't even have an idea of what the
hunger games was
happy hunger games and may the odds be
ever in your favor
of course you could argue that as the
movies went on the audience got older so
they could have at the very least amped
their rating up to a 14a
but then the continuity would have been
messed up imagine if you had a tame
version of the hunger games and then
suddenly jumped to a catching fire that
included all the horrors the books did
it definitely would have felt disjointed
nonetheless
it was successful in films like harry
potter where the characters were growing
up alongside the audiences it definitely
could have been made possible
why do you think they decided to keep
their rating at a constant pg-13
even with their more tame rating all
four hunger games films managed to keep
their dark atmosphere without some of
the books most morbid scenes
not to mention they still managed to
create a cultural phenomenon in the film
world
but we can't help but wonder what the
franchise could have been if the
filmmakers had taken that leap down the
dark path
that's a particular savvy in that isn't
there
would you watch a more twisted version
of the hunger games don't forget to let
us know below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and we'll see you in another video
thanks for watching
you